le cadre de nos travaux respectifs sur
le projet de loi relatif à l'industrie
verte qui sera examinée en séance
publique je vous le rappelle le 20 juin
prochain nous recevons aujourd'hui
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
et Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie l'examen
de ce projet de loi a été renvoyé à la
commission des affaires économiques
comme vous le savez mais 12 articles sur
les 19 que compte le texte aujourd'hui
ont été délégués au fond respectivement
à la commission du développement durable
des lois et des Finances c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir ce soir nos collègues des
quatre commissions vous serez indulgent
avec moi si je ne vois pas tous les
doigts se lever voilà Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire vous vous êtes donné comme
objectif de remonter la part de
l'industrie dans le PIB français de 10 à
15%. il s'agit bien entendu pour la
France de recréer de l'emploi mais il
s'agit aussi et surtout de assurer que
la France conservera dans les années à
venir des capacités de production
autonomes en particulier dans les
secteurs critiques qui soutiendront la
transition verte et plus largement dans
les secteurs stratégiques pour la
souveraineté française nous partageons
bien sûr ces objectifs en tout cas avec
les corps-à-porteurs Franck Montauger et
Amel gacquet avec qui nous avons commis
un rapport sur la souveraineté française
économique nous partageons bien sûr ces
objectifs il me semble aussi que la
philosophie générale du projet de loi
qui vise à concilier de manière
dynamique développement industriel et
transition verte doit être saluée c'est
pour nous une évidence mais il est
indispensable de répéter que la
transition écologique se fera avec et
grâce à nos industriels et bien sûr pas
contre eux nous partageons donc votre
ambition mais je dois vous dire que le
détail des mesures proposées adapt dans
le texte nous laisse un petit peu sur
notre fin
vous nous promettiez le 16 mai je cite
les instruments révolutionnaires nous
avons trouvé dans ce texte des mesures
techniques
ultra ciblées qui ne nous semble
d'ailleurs pas particulièrement ciblé la
décarbonation de l'industrie et la
création d'industrie verte en France je
le répète tout cela va dans le bon sens
dans le bon sens mais sans doute vous
nous expliquerait en quoi ces
dispositifs sont de nature à rompre de
façon révolutionnaire avec des décennies
de désindustrialisation car à première
vue nous sommes encore un peu sceptique
je laisserai mes collègues rapporteurs
qui sont en face vous interrogez plus
précisément sur les articles qui
relèvent de leur périmètre mais je
souhaiterais vous poser quelques
questions d'ordre général premièrement
vous avez annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures fiscales notamment à crédit
d'impôt investissement industriel verte
mais sa création est renvoyée à la
prochaine loi de finances or tous les
industriels avec lesquels nous
échangeons insistent sur le fait que à
ses dispositions fiscales ainsi que le
volet aide public seront les plus
insistes incitatives pour eux face au
financement massif consentis par le
gouvernement américain dans l'Iran et
alors que vous le dites vous-même il y a
urgence à attirer de nouveaux
investissements n'aurait-il pas été
précieux de ne pas perdre les six
prochains mois deuxièmement nous avons
besoin de clarification sur le périmètre
des industries qui seront éligibles au
dispositions prévues par le projet de
loi je pense en particulier aux
procédures dérogatoires en matière
d'urbanisme pour lesquels on parle dans
le texte tantôt de secteur des
technologies favorables au développement
durable ou tantôt de projets concourant
à la transition écologique quelles sont
ces secteurs comment seront-ils définis
et bien sûr sur quels critères il y a
notamment une question d'articulation
avec le droit européen puisque le futur
règlement net 0 industrie actuellement
en cours de négociation vice précisément
comme votre d'autres projets de loi à
faciliter l'implantation d'industrie
verte en Europe et afflécher les
financements la place du nucléaire dans
ce règlement fait par exemple débat ce
n'est pas une question anodine pour la
France et nous souhaiterions
déclarification sur le traitement de la
filière nucléaire dans le projet de loi
enfin au Sénat chambre des territoires
vous ne pouviez pas ne pas être
interrogé sur le fameux article 9 qui
réussit l'exploit à faire l'unanimité
contre lui alors que tout le monde
s'accorde par ailleurs sur sa finalité
qui est d'accélérer les délais
administratifs d'implantation
industrielle pour nos collègues je
précise que l'article 9 crée une
nouvelle procédure d'autorisation
d'urbanisme qui permettrait au préfet
pour des projets qualifiés par décret
d'intérêt national majeur pour la
souveraineté nationale ou la transition
écologique de mettre en compatibilité
d'office l'ensemble des documents de
planification et d'urbanisme concernés
pour permettre la réalisation du projet
à ce stade aucune concertation avec les
élus locaux n'est prévu vous justifiez
là encore cette disposition par la
nécessité d'aller plus vite que nous
partageons mais accordez-moi que c'est
faire porter au collectivités aux élus
locaux la responsabilité des longueurs
procédurales qui ne sont pas de leur
fait mais nous savons tous qui découlent
de la surabondance de raide de
concertation d'enquête et l'incapacité
souvent des services déconcentrés de
l'État devenu famélique à traiter et
accompagné correctement les projets qui
émanent des territoires personnellement
je ne connais pas un seul maire ou un
seul président de région qui
s'opposerait au développement économique
de son territoire mais peut-être en
connaissez-vous monsieur le ministre et
peut-être pouvez-vous nous expliquer
pourquoi selon vous seul l'État serait
capable de faire vite et bien évidemment
je finirai par là cette procédure hyper
dérogatoire de l'article 9 et d'autant
plus inacceptable qu'aucune disposition
n'est prévue parallèlement pour ex les
collectivités et les régions où seraient
implantés ces grands projets industriels
du fameux des contes du zan et ceci
contrairement l'engagement qui avait été
pris par votre collègue Christophe Béchu
lors de l'examen de la PPL sénatoriale
zan dans notre hémicycle en mars dernier
quand sera-t-il au final comment
envisagez-vous de traiter ces grands
projets et les projets industriels de
manière générale au regard du Zane les
représentants de la Commission spéciale
zan que je vois présence ce soir ne
manqueront pas de vous interroger
j'imagine sur ce sujet je vous laisse
donc la parole puis ensuite nous
prendrons les questions des rapporteurs
puis de l'ensemble de nos collègues avec
une contrainte qui est de terminer au
plus tard à 19h45 voilà mes chers
collègues
merci madame la Présidente chère Sophie
primat monsieur le ministre Roland
Lescure la même issue les rapporteurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs je suis très heureux de vous
présenter pour la première fois devant
l'ensemble des commissions concernées ce
projet de loi sur l'industrie verte en
compagnie du ministre de l'Industrie
roulant Lescure projet de loi qui est
décisif pour accélérer la
réindustrialisation notre pays et
réussir la transition écologique
pourquoi ce projet de loi sur
l'industrie verte parce que nous avons
une dette et parce que nous avons un
défi
nous avons une dette vis-à-vis de la
nation en matière industrielle cette
dette industrielle c'est 40 années de
délocalisation industrielle au nom du
concept fumeu de l'industrie sans usine
portée par les élites politiques et les
édits économiques à l'unanimité ou
presse pendant des années ce concept
fumeu il s'est traduit par 2,5 millions
d'emplois détruits
600 usines fermées une part de
l'industrie dans le PIB qui est tombé de
20 à 10% là où il est resté à 23% en
Allemagne et stabilisé à 18% en Italie
cette dette industrielle c'est un drame
économique pour notre nation qui a perdu
de ses capacités de production c'est un
drame social en particulier pour les
ouvriers et les familles d'ouvriers qui
ont subi cette désindustrialisation de
masse et s'étein écologique
parce que tout ce qui n'est plus produit
en France dans des conditions
environnementales satisfaisantes est
importée de pays qui ne respectent pas
les mêmes conditions environnementales
et dans le fond tous les efforts que
nous faisons pour réduire nos émissions
de CO2 sur le territoire national sont
plus que compensés par l'importation de
CO2 venu d'autres pays extérieurs à
l'Union européenne nous avons commencé
avec le président de la République a
engagé cette reconquête industrielle
depuis 6 ans et nous l'avons fait en
prenant toutes les décisions courageuses
que d'autres ont refusé de prendre je
pense en particulier aux décisions
fiscales qui ne sont pas les plus
populaires mais qui sont les plus
nécessaires l'industrie c'est du capital
garder une imposition très lourde sur le
capital c'était ruiné notre industrie
l'industrie c'est de la compétitivité
garder des impôts de production cette
fois plus élevés que nos voisins
allemands s'étaient ruinés notre
industrie l'industrie c'est des
compétences
dévaloriser des métiers industriels
alors que nous avons besoin de
chaudronnier de soudeur de techniciens
de maintenance d'ingénieurs c'était tué
notre industrie nous avons depuis plus
de 6 ans maintenant renversé la tendance
ouvert 300 usines donc nous avons
quasiment rattrapé la moitié de ce qui
avait été détruit et créé pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans 90
000 emplois industriels dans notre pays
nous avons même réussi l'exploit de
recréer pour la première fois depuis
Airbus de nouvelles filières
industrielles l'usine gigafactory de
batterie électrique que j'ai inauguré
hier à Douvrin
après quatre années de scepticisme
généralisés va nous permettre de
rattraper notre retard par rapport à la
Chine en matière de production de
batterie électrique et s'il y a une
sénatrice ou un sénateur ici ce que je
ne pense pas qui doute de la capacité de
la France à gagner cette bataille
industrielle je l'invite à aller visiter
cette usine de batterie électrique de
Douvres qui montrent que nous avons les
technologies de savoir-faire l'envie le
financement les entreprises privées et
la vision de long terme qui doivent nous
permettre de faire remonter la part de
l'industrie dans le PNB de 10 à 15% dans
les années qui viennent
nous avons également un défi le défi
c'est la transition écologique la
transition écologique change
radicalement la donne de l'économie
mondiale
d'abord parce qu'elle demande une
électricité décarbonée massive c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président de la
République a présenté un plan en trois
axes sobriété énergies renouvelables
développement de nouvelles énergies
nucléaires en deuxième lieu parce que
comme la parfaitement indiqué le rapport
Pisani Ferry sur lequel je reviendrai
nous allons avoir des besoins de
financement de l'ordre de 60 à 70
milliards d'euros pour cette
décarbonation et en troisième lieu parce
que cette transition écologique nous
place face à un choix politique au sens
le plus noble du terme
pour réduire les émissions de CO2 il y a
dans le fond de grandes options la
première c'est la décroissance produire
moins importer plus
cette solution nous la refusons la
deuxième option c'est la croissance
verte produire plus mais produire mieux
en investissant massivement dans les
technologies vertes et dans l'industrie
verte c'est la voie que nous vous
proposons avec ce projet de loi sur
l'industrie verte
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'industrie
verte ces deux choses différentes mais
complémentaires la première chose c'est
la décarbonation des industries
existantes et je vous le dis avec
beaucoup de force à tous les ouvriers
qui s'inquiètent à tous les ingénieurs à
toutes les PME industrielles qui
maillent notre territoire dont vous êtes
les représentants nous ne laisserons pas
tomber l'industrie traditionnelle
notre objectif n'est pas de remplacer
une industrie par une autre notre
premier objectif doit être de décarboner
l'industrie existante la deuxième chose
c'est que nous voulons dans le même
temps produire de nouvelles technologies
vertes de nouveaux produits verts c'est
ce que j'appelle les Big Five les 5
grandes technologies essentielles à la
transition écologique les pompes à
chaleur les panneaux photovoltaïques les
batteries électriques pour les véhicules
électriques l'hydrogène vert et les
produits éoliens voilà les 5 grands
secteurs économiques dans lesquels nous
voulons investir pour l'industrie verte
comment est-ce que nous voulons y
parvenir et comment est-ce que c'est 19
articles de loi vont nous permettre
d'opérer ce que j'appelle effectivement
cette révolution industrielle verte car
il y a bien je répondrai à la question
de la présidente une révolution dans la
conception des projets dans leur
financement et dans leur ambition
le premier défi auquel nous sommes
confrontés pour être très pragmatique
vous voulez tous ici c'est quand un
investisseur français ou étranger vient
en France pour bâtir une usine il
cherche un terrain
vous avez été maire et du locaux je l'ai
été aussi chacun sait bien que ce qui
fait le plus défauts notre territoire
merveilleux mais plus petit que d'autres
c'est du terrain à bâtir et notamment du
terrain pour l'industrie
il est essentiel d'abord que ce terrain
soit disponible rapidement une fois
qu'il a été
identifié il faut que les procédures
aillent plus vite premier élément de
révolution nous proposons de diviser par
deux le délai d'instruction des
ouvertures ou des agencesments de site
industriels pour le passé d'un peu plus
de 18 mois à 9 mois avec une méthode que
nous assumons qui je le sais va faire
débat qui est le passé d'une procédure
successive à une procédure parallèle
aujourd'hui nous avons une procédure
successive où les différentes étapes se
succèdent des unes après les autres avec
évidemment entre chaque étape des
transitions qui peuvent durer hélas
plusieurs semaines et qui nous amènent à
ces fameux 18 mois d'abord on dépose le
dossier il est analysé par la DREAL puis
vient la ville d'autorité
environnementale puis vient l'enquête
publique puis vient le rapport de
commissaire enquêteur puis vient la
rédaction de l'arrêté d'autorisation
pour total réel de 18 mois
nous proposons que l'ensemble de ces
procédures soit menées ensemble pour
gagner un temps considérable tout en
ayant d'ailleurs une consultation
publique plus approfondie s'agit pas de
faire ça au détriment des exigences
environnementales ou détriment des
exigences de consultation du public mais
de les concentrer en un même temps pour
nous assurer que les délais sont
comparables ce qui est pratiqués dans
tous les autres pays européens sans quoi
nous n'avons aucune chance de gagner
cette bataille industrielle
le deuxième élément c'est que même si il
pourrait resteront vite encore faut-il
que le foncier soit disponible pour
avoir plus de fonciers disponibles de
proposons un certain nombre de mesures
nous proposons d'abord avec la banque
des territoires de mettre à disposition
un certain nombre de sites clés en main
qui seront financés par la Banque des
territoires nous proposons de rosser la
création environnementale au rang des
créances privilégiées pour la première
fois en France de façon à ce que les
industriels soient responsables de la
dépollution des sites là aussi tous ceux
c'est-à-dire je pense la totalité des
présences dans cette salle qui ont été
élus locaux savent bien que payer pour
la dépollution revient en général à la
charge de la collectivité locale ou de
l'État et que l'entreprise peut s'en
décharger nous souhaitons qu'elles
deviennent responsables en rehaussant la
créance environnementale enfin nous
proposons la
présidente on a parlé d'accélérer les
projets d'intérêt national majeur dessus
je veux être très parce que
l'interrogation de la présidente est
parfaitement légitime cette procédure
d'exception ne concernerait que les
sites majeurs comme les giga Factory des
projets à plusieurs milliards d'euros
représentants des milliers d'emplois
l'idée que l'État puisse prendre la main
pour accélérer les procédures mais je
suis évidemment ouvert mon remettant à
la sagesse des sénatrices et des
sénateurs à des possibilités
d'amendement sous forme par exemple
d'avis conforme des élus locaux qui
pourraient dire oui il faut que l'État
puisse accélérer sur ce projet
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est fait à
Dunkerque sur la gigafactory que nous
avons ouverte et obtenu pour les
batteries ion lithium solides réalisées
par prologum et ça c'est fait en parfait
dansante avec les élus locaux donc je
suggère sur la recommandation toujours
sage la présidente de la commission de
phase économique du Sénat que nous
amendions le texte sur ce point pour
nous assurer que cela ne se fait jamais
contre judoko on ne fait rien dans un
territoire contre les îles locaux cela
n'existe pas dans une démocratie et cela
ne doit pas exister en France donc je
suis évidemment ouvert à toute
proposition d'amendement sur le sujet
deuxième élément une fois que nous avons
trouvé le terrain
établi les normes pour que ce terrain
soit disponible accélérer les procédures
pour que l'investisseur ne partent pas
au bout de quelques instants en disant
c'est trop long faut financer le projet
pour financer le projet je rappelle que
nous allons avoir besoin de capitaux
pour des montants extraordinairement
élevés
nous proposons d'abord de mobiliser
l'épargne privée que ce soit sous forme
d'unité de compte dans les plans
d'assurance vie où nous proposons qu'il
y ait une obligation légale d'avoir une
unité de compte servant au financement
des projets pour l'industrie verte sur
les plans d'épargne retraite sur le
livret développement durable et
solidaire dans les fonds doivent être
orientés vers l'industrie via ce qui ne
sont pas aujourd'hui ou par la mise en
place d'un plan d'épargne climat nous
attendons un milliard d'euros de
collecte de ce plan d'épargne climat qui
pourrait être ouvert pour tous les
jeunes ayant moins de 18 ans la
naissance de votre enfant avec un taux
de rémunération qui devrait être
supérieur à celui du livret A parce que
l'investissement est le long terme et
avec des conditions fiscales
exceptionnelles puisque nous avons
décidé que à la sortie de ce livret il y
aura zéro charge et 0 impôts il n'y a
aucun placement en France excepté de
livrer a
qui bénéficie de telles règles
dérogatoires en matière de fiscalité ce
qui rendra je pense ce plan d'épargne de
climat très attractif pour les parents
et leurs enfants au total avec la seule
épargne des ménages nous comptons
mobilisés 5 milliards d'euros d'épargne
privé pour le financement de l'industrie
verte je dis au passage même si je salue
du travail remarquable qui était fait
par Jean Pisani Ferri dans son rapport
que c'est exactement le montant de l'ISS
vert je préfère mobiliser l'épargne que
créer un nouvel impôt en tout cas c'est
ma conviction
enfin dans le financement nous prévoyons
effectivement comme la rappeler la
présidente de la commission la mise en
place d'un crédit d'impôt je rappelle
que n'existe aujourd'hui que des
subventions ces subventions sont déjà
par rapport à ce qui existaient dans un
temps très lointain ou j'ai démarré
comme ministre de l'économie et des
finances sont déjà une véritable
révolution il y a six ans il était hors
de question d'apporter des aides d'État
un projet industriel nous avons réussi à
obtenir avec le président de la
République la Commission européenne une
véritable révolution idéologique avec la
mise en place des programmes d'intérêts
collectifs européens ou pour la première
fois chaque État européen à la liberté
sur un projet industriel de dire vous
venez je vous donne 100 200 millions 500
millions parfois des sommes plus
importantes qui se chiffre en milliard
on peut le regretter mais c'était ça ou
aucun projet industriel ne s'implantait
en Europe que ce soit sur les batteries
les semi-conducteurs les véhicules
électriques l'industrie automobile ou
d'autres investissements tout se
répartis en Chine aux États-Unis puisque
Chine comme les États-Unis propose des
aides d'État massives aux industriels
pour s'implanter sur leur sol ce que le
Chine est État-Unis ont et que nous
n'avions pas jusqu'à présent c'est des
crédits d'impôts non seulement si vous
installez on vous offre une subvention
au départ mais en plus on vous donne un
crédit d'impôt pour votre production
c'est ce que vous proposons de faire
pour 4 des 5 productions toutes les
productions industrielles vertes que
j'ai signé cité à l'exception de
l'hydrogène pour une raison qui est très
simple nous avons déjà mis 9,2 milliards
d'euros d'investissement sur l'hydrogène
dans le cadre du Plan France 2030 nous
estimons qu'il ne faut pas rajouter de
créer d'impôts et que des coûts seraient
trop élevés pour les finances publiques
comment est-ce que nous finançons ce
crédit d'impôts nous le finançons par la
réduction des niches fiscales chez
Énergie fossiles proposons par exemple
que la fiscalité soit alourdie sur les
véhicules les plus lourds aujourd'hui
c'est 1,8 tonnes nous proposons
d'abaisser le seuil à 1,7 ou 1,6 t nous
proposons de mettre fin au plafonnement
du malus automobile à 50 % du la valeur
du véhicule automobile là aussi pour
financer ce crédit d'impôt
enfin pour répondre à la question de la
présidence il me semble que nous pouvons
attendre le PLF pour le faire même si ce
sujet doit être débattu à l'occasion du
projet de loi industrie verte simplement
le vote du projet loint industrie verte
sera une indication pour nos
investisseurs de notre capacité à mettre
en place un crédit d'impôt au PLF 2024
une fois que le site a été trouvé que le
projet a été financé il est
indispensable de mieux protéger nos
investissements industriels et c'est la
troisième révolution parce que l'Union
européenne de manière générale la France
également ont trop longtemps hésité à
protéger leurs investissements donc vous
commencez à le faire avec les
investissements étrangers en France mais
nous voulons je ne le cache pas utiliser
toutes les normes environnementales pour
valoriser
protéger défendre notre industrie
nationale nous mettrons ainsi en place
un label triple e excellent
environnementale européenne qui donnera
un bonus à toute entreprise qui veut
avoir accès privilégié à la commande
publique qui je le rappelle représente
150 milliards d'euros nous voulons
changer la culture des acheteurs
économiques et des acheteurs publics
pour que les critères écologiques soient
appréciés au même niveau que les
critères économiques véritable
révolution culturelle pour protéger nos
entreprises qui sont à travers la
planète les plus vertueuses je rappelle
contre un véhicule électrique produit en
France ou un véhicule électrique produit
en Chine le véhicule électrique produit
en Chine émet 46% de plus de CO2 à la
production nous avons donc intérêt à
utiliser ces normes environnementales
pour protéger notre production nous le
ferons également et c'est là aussi une
véritable révolution pour le bonus
électrique le bonus électrique
représente 1,2 milliards d'euros
sous forme d'aide de 5000 à 7000 euros
quand vous allez acheter un véhicule
électrique à votre concession 40% de ce
bonus va valent les usines chinoises
je suis très heureux que dans les usines
chinois soient produits des véhicules
français mais il se trouve qu'après ça
ne va pas en France ça ne va pas pour
des salariés françaises ça ne va pas
pour des ouvriers français ça va pour
des usines en Chine grand bien leurs
faces pour les usines en Chine mais le
concert français n'a pas vocation à
financer le développement des usines
chinoises raison pour laquelle nous
proposons de mettre en place des normes
environnementales plus strictes qui
permettront de réserver ce bonus
électrique ou seul véhicule produit sur
le sol européen dans les conditions
environnementales les plus exigeantes
voilà les grands éléments de ce projet
de loi madame la Présidente il me semble
que c'est un projet de loi stratégique
pour la nation française qui marque un
double tournant vers l'industrie et vers
la transition écologique je souhaite que
quel que soit notre appartenance
politique nous puissions dégager une
majorité sur ce texte au Sénat et je ne
vous cache pas que je suis heureux de
l'examen de ce texte commence dans votre
assemblée
bien oui monsieur le ministre Roland
Lescure
Sophie prima monsieur le ministre
Cherbourg mesdames et messieurs et
notamment madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs peut-être pour illustrer sur
quelques exemples très concrets que nous
cherchons à faire nous étions hier tous
les deux mais avec un certain nombre
d'entre vous à l'inauguration à Douvrin
de l'usine à CC ça c'est pour je dirais
l'industrie de la décarbonation à cessé
la demande d'autorisation est dates il y
a deux ans quasiment jour pour jour
début juin 2021 en deux ans on a réussi
à obtenir les autorisations et à
construire une usine et à l'inaugurer le
30 mai 2023 ça c'est l'exception et il
faut que ça devienne la règle évidemment
pour faire ça on a aligné l'ensemble des
élus locaux nationaux l'ensemble des
services administratifs il y a eu une
volonté très forte d'avancer donc ça
prouve qu'on sait le faire qu'on peut le
faire mais pour ça la meilleure manière
de le faire c'est que les règles
deviennent en phase avec ces débats et
donc de modéliser les débats ça c'est
pour l'industrie de la décarbonation on
a un autre exemple en tête sur la
décarbonation de l'industrie
traditionnelle puisque même la
présidente vous nous demandiez un peu la
différence entre les deux nous étions là
aussi avec Bruno Le Maire à Dombasle le
9 novembre dernier chez le rapporteur
général du budget je sais pas s'il est
là ainsi que le sénateur Olivier Jacquin
chez Solvay Solvay pour installer une
nouvelle
chaudière qui permet de décarboner un
processus extrêmement carbonent avec là
encore l'alignement de tout le monde il
a fallu dix mois d'autorisation là où on
veut viser 6 9 maximum donc ce projet de
loi il interviendra de manière très
concrète pour accélérer ces procédures
et faire en sorte que les les industries
traditionnelles tout comme les
industries de la décarbonation puisse
aller plus vite
deuxième exemple très important Bruno
l'a évoqué rapidement dans son
introduction nous souhaitons favoriser
la circularité industrielle le recyclage
des déchets parce qu'une phiné les
matières premières qu'on ne consomme pas
parce que elles viennent d'un processus
industriel évidemment c'est un pas de
géant sur la voie de l'économie et de
l'environnement aujourd'hui il faut que
vous sachiez que il faut au moins un an
de procédure pour sortir un déchet
industriel qui pourrait être directement
réutilisés dans une usine de la
procédure dite de déchet est une
procédure européenne pour laquelle une
fois n'est pas coutume la France a
décidé d'avoir une procédure plus
contraignante que le reste de l'Union
européenne donc vous pouvez choisir soit
la procédure explicite soit sur la
procédure implicite la plupart des pays
ont choisi ce qu'on appelle la procédure
implicite qui est que si l'industriel
respecte un certain de nos critères il
peut réutiliser ces déchets dans son
processus nous on a fait une déclaration
préalable pour être très concret
chez monsieur le rapporteur saumon il
connaît sans doute l'entreprise l'étoile
qui est une finale du relais qui recycle
des textiles et qui en fait des chiffons
il faut que vous sachiez que pour
recycler des textiles usagés et en faire
des chiffons en France il a fallu un an
de procédure tout pour demander
l'autorisation formelle de réutiliser
des textils usagers en chiffon après ce
projet de loi ce sera implicite ce sera
automatique qui suffira d'une
déclaration de l'entreprise pour qu'on
puisse recycler nos textiles en chiffon
je pense que c'est peut-être pas
révolutionnaire on a le président mais
c'est quand même assez bienvenu et ça va
permettre d'accélérer là aussi des
procédures y compris dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire puisque c'est
d'exemple que je donne
je ne serai pas plus long si ce n'est
vous dire pour compléter les les propos
de du ministre sur le financement que
j'ai eu l'honneur et le plaisir de
travailler au Canada dans une entreprise
d'investissement public qui investissait
à peu près 300 ou 400 milliards de
dollars canadiens et notamment une
grande partie dans l'économie local et
dans l'économie de la décarbonation en
France notre grand investisseur
institutionnel c'est la banque publique
d'investissement elle investit 44
milliards d'euros au total donc on a
vraiment besoin de mobiliser l'épargne
privée pour le faire je pense que les
outils que nous vous proposons nous
permettrons de le faire merci Madame
très bien merci beaucoup à partir des
exemples que vous nous avez donné on va
avoir plein de cas à vous soumettre sur
les surtances positions je vais
commencer par donner la parole aux
quatre rapporteurs et je vais commencer
par Laurent saumon et ensuite dans
l'ordre Didier Jean-Yves roux et
cristinaba Laurent monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues le projet
de loi qui nous est présenté dénommé
industries vertes proposent deux
objectifs la réindustrialisation de
notre pays en favorisant l'implantation
de nouvelles entreprises en insérant la
planification industrielle dans les
stradettes c'est l'article 1
naturellement qui est intéressant qui
n'est assez qui n'est pas contesté en
simplifiant et réduisant les délais vous
en avez parlé monsieur le ministre et la
consultation du public dès la
recevabilité de de la demande
d'autorisation environnementale dont on
parlera sûrement mes collègues
rapporteurs la réhabilitation des
friches notamment par l'amélioration les
frigestimés à 87000 hectares en France
en améliorant la procédure du tiers
demandeur et de favoriser le recyclage
du foncier industriel avec la
seigneurisation des dépenses de mise en
sécurité environnementale comme vous
l'avez précisé qui sont d'un intérêt
très positif et l'ambition de faciliter
le dispositif site clé en main à ce
propos vous l'estimez à 2000 hectares il
essaierait intéressant de connaître pour
ce sera sûrement pour accueillir les
pays inmm les projets d'intérêt
nationaux majeurs quel est la réflexion
que vous avez sur ce sujet et comment ou
et où seront-ils fléchés cette
réindustrialisation et la décarbonation
nécessite la cohérence avec le
développement du futur mix énergétique
mais la présidente en a parlé je n'y
reviendrai pas une fiscalisation que
vous avez évoquée la disponibilité d'un
foncier accessible sans opérer les
nécessités environnementales à préserver
malgré une réglementation allégée dont
parlerons sûrement les collègues
quand vous l'avez précisé monsieur le
ministre pour réussir nous avons besoin
de foncer dans un pays qui n'est pas
extensible avez-vous dit c'est un défi
considérable 10000 à 20 000 hectares
nécessaires pour vous 20 30 000 pour le
président de la République j'y
reviendrai le rapport Gilot a fait le
constat de délai d'installation
industriels plus long vous en avez parlé
aussi ce qui a valu dans la PJL les
mesures favorisant les délais de
délivrance de l'autorisation
environnementale quelle analyse
avez-vous cependant fait de ce constat
on avait vous conclu mais la présidente
prime en a parlé de la responsabilité
majeure des collectivités locales dans
le processus de délivrance des permis
pour revenir plus pratiquement sur un
certain nombre de sujets les articles 8
et 9 du projet de loi qui vise à
accélérer les procédures d'autorisation
d'urbanisme prévoit que pourront
bénéficier respectivement les implations
d'installation industrielle je cite dans
les secteurs des technologies favorables
au développement durable et les projets
industriels je cite d'intérêt national
majeurs pour la souveraineté nationale
ou la transition écologique tout ça
demeure quand même un peu similaire
pouvez-vous nous donner des précisions
sur les secteurs qui seront inclus dans
le périmètre de ces articles
seront-ils
ceux qui sont couverts par le futur
règlement européen industrie 0.net la
présence du nucléaire au sein de ce
règlement ne fait pas consensus le
secteur nucléaire fera t-il dans tous
les cas partie des secteurs couverts par
la future loi sur l'industrie verte
l'article 9 du projet de loi prévoit une
procédure super accélérée de
modification des documents planification
et d'urbanisme pour les projets je cite
d'intérêt national majeurs pour les
souverainetés nationales ou la
transition écologique dont la liste
serait fixé par décret l'ensemble de la
procédure serait à la main donc l'état
la participation des élus est en réduite
à la pension congrue mais la présidente
en a parlé également j'aurais cependant
quatre questions premièrement comment
ces projets d'intérêt national majeurs
seront-ils définis par qui sur quels
critères avec quelles périodicité
l'article premier du projet de loi
renforce les compétences économiques de
la région en matière de planification
industrielle trouvez-vous cohérent de la
même de ne même pas prévoir de
consultation des régions sur
l'établissement de la liste des projets
industriels d'intérêt national majeurs
je ne parle pas bien sûr même là des
collectivités locales deuxièmement
pouvez-vous nous donner des exemples
concrets de ce qui pourrait être
considéré comme un grand projet mais
vous en avez cité quelques-uns à
l'instant combien de projets cela
représente-t-il et pour quelle
superficie totale troisièmement nous
partageons tous le souci de réduire les
délais d'implantation industrie mais
cela implique-t-il de déposséder les
collectivités de leurs compétences les
temps et l'État est-il le seul à vouloir
aller vite quatrièmement avec cette
nouvelle procédure l'État pourrait
unilatéralement au collectivité de
modifier les stradettes et les documents
d'urbanisme cela pourrait-il aller
jusqu'à modifier la répartition
territoriale du zan cela pourrait-il
aller jusqu'à mettre les collectivités
concernées avec les objectifs de
réduction de l'artificialisation que la
loi leur a fixée vous nous dites qu'il
est urgent de réindustrialiser nous
partageons cette urgence or nous voyons
dans les territoires des projets
industriels retardés ou annulés au motif
du zan particulièrement que les
collectivités sont mises en situation de
choisir notamment entre le développement
économique et le logement nous avons
pour le moins été surpris de ne trouver
dans le projet de loi aucun dispositif
d'exemption des projets industriels du
décompte du zan que votre collègue
Christophe Béchu nous avait pourtant
annoncé lors de l'examen en séance au
Sénat de la PPL zan qu'en est-il
soutenez-vous l'exemption des projets
industriels du décompte du zan à au
moins à titre transistors le président
de la République a évoqua a évoqué
pardon des besoins en fonciers de 20 à
30 000 hectares pour tenir les objectifs
de réindustrialisation est-ce aussi le
chiffre que vous retenez parce qu'il
n'était pas le même dans pro sur ce
total combien se préoccuper par les
grands projets combien le ferait sur le
ferait-il sur des friches combien en
artificialisation nouvelle et enfin la
valorisation des friches et l'une des
clés pour détendre la contrainte sur le
foncier éviter les conflits d'usage que
le zan a déjà commencé de créer sur les
territoires c'est donc une des clés de
la réindustrialisation selon le préfet
Rollon Mouchel blezo que vous avez
chargé d'une mission interministérielle
de mobilisation pour le foncier
industriel ce sont environ 8000 hectares
de friches qu'il faudrait requalifier
pour les seuls besoins industriels dans
les prochaines années au-delà des
timides mesures de libération du foncier
industrielle figurant dans le projet de
loi quelle mesure prévoyez-vous pour
accompagner les collectivités dans la
valorisation de ces fonciers souvent
pollués dont la réhabilitation est
particulièrement coûteuse merci
monsieur le rapporteur
on va essayer d'être un peu plus concis
voilà merci Président Monsieur les
ministres je souhaite vous interroger
sur trois points qui ont appelé
l'attention de mon collègue Fabien
Jeunet rapporteur pour avis pour la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
et de développement durable qui n'a plus
se libérer pour l'audition de ce soir et
vous prie de m'excuser premièrement
j'aimerais que nous abordions plus en
détail l'évolution des procédures de
consultation dans le cadre
d'autorisation environnementale que
proposait à l'article 2 du projet de loi
le point saillant de cette réforme et la
paralysation des procédures qui permet
de mener de front la phase d'examen et
la phase d'instruction ainsi d'accélérer
la procédure d'autorisation
environnementale comme vous l'avez
évoqué cette mesure accélérer deux
faites la procédure à condition que le
projet change peu pendant la phase
d'examen
cependant qu'en est-il si l'exploitant
est amené à apporter les modifications
substantielles qui remettraient en cause
l'équilibre général du projet dans ce
cas de figure cette parallélisation des
procédures n'est-elle pas un facteur
d'allongement des délais pareil pourquoi
avoir décidé de créer une nouvelle
procédure de participation du public
addock plutôt que de réformer la
procédure d'enquête publique actuelle le
droit de la participation du public
n'est-il pas aujourd'hui suffisamment
complexe deuxièmement je souhaite
appeler à votre attention une
disposition spécifique du même article 2
qui pourrait à première vue ne semblait
être qu'un détail technique vous
supprimez une disposition introduite par
le Sénat à mon initiative dans la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables promulguées il y a
seulement deux mois le droit actuel
prévoit que pour les projets d'énergie
renouvelables situés dans une zone
d'accélération la phase d'examen du
projet est limitée à 4 mois cette limite
est supprimée alors que la réforme de la
phase d'examen consultation que vous
proposez n'offre pas de garantie
équivalente pourquoi avoir supprimé
cette disposition par ailleurs puisque
vous tenez intégrer dans le ce projet de
loi la question du délai d'examen des
projets ENR ne s'agit-il pas d'une
opportunité pour transposer le délai
maximum de 12 mois pour les procédures
d'instruction des projets d'énergie
renouvelables situés dans les zones
d'accélération prévues par la directive
red 3 en cours d'adoption au niveau
européen troisièmement dernier point je
souhaite évoquer la problématique de la
mise en sécurité et de la réhabilitation
des friches industrielles les plus
spécialement l'article 6 vous
restreignez le périmètre de la garantie
financière que doivent effectuer les
exploitants d'installation classée ICPE
en raison l'inefficacité avérée de ce
dispositif pour assurer malgré la
suppression de cette garantie la mise en
sécurité du site puis sa réhabilitation
en cas de défaillance de l'exploitant
vous instaurez une consigne et une
nouvelle amende qui peuvent être
ordonnées par le préfet en cas
d'installation illégale ainsi qu'une
seigneurisation des créances en cas de
liquidation judiciaires dans le cas de
l'exploitation n'est pas installé
également et n'est pas non plus en
liquidation judiciaire de quels outils
disposent ou disposeront demain les
autorités pour contraindre une
entreprise à respecter ses obligations
de remise en état de réhabilitation en
supprimant la garantie financière ne
risquez-vous pas au final de ralentir la
réhabilitation des friches industrielles
dans le cas que je vais d'évoquer merci
merci beaucoup Didier Monsieur Jean
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres comme mes collègues
rapporteurs je souhaite vous interroger
au nom de la commission des lois qui est
saisie sur les articles 12 et 13 du
projet de loi relatif au verdissement de
la commande publique je vous poserai
qu'une seule question mais que je vais
légèrement développer car elle soulève
une vraie difficulté de terrain que nous
devons prendre en compte avant de voter
sur ces deux articles je souhaite en
effet vous faire part du viveteau humain
que j'ai ressenti à découvrant au fil
des auditions à quel point les motifs
d'exclusion des procédures de passation
des marchés publics et des contrats de
concession étaient inutile unités les
motifs d'exclusion dit de plein droit ne
font l'objet que d'une déclaration sur
l'honneur qui n'est visiblement pas
contrôlé les motifs d'exclusion dit à
l'appréciation de l'acheteur ne sont à
eux jamais utilisés vraisemblablement
par crainte de futurs contentieux j'en
veux pourquoi suite à l'audition de la
direction des affaires juridiques de
votre ministère à fournir la moindre
estimation même très approximative du
nombre d'entreprises concernées par des
exclusions de plein droit des procédures
de passation des marchés publics j'en
conclus qu'il existe aucun suivi de cet
outil qui nous est pourtant présenté
comme un puissant moyen de verdissement
de la commande publique de façon plus
problématique encore lugiape nous a
affirmé n'avoir jamais et je dis bien
jamais fait usage des cas d'exclusion
des procédures de passation de marché
public il est pourtant demandé au
législateur que nous sommes d'ajouter
dans le code de la commande publique
deux nouveaux motifs d'exclusion des
procédures de passation des marchés
publics je souhaite m'assurer que notre
vote ne sera pas vain ma question est
donc la suivante j'ai qu'une question
comptez-vous donner les directives afin
que les acheteurs publics s'approprient
davantage la possibilité qu'offre le
code de la commande publique en matière
d'exclusion des procédures de passation
des marchés publics notamment celle qui
sont à l'appréciation de la chasseur je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur et pour finir en beauté
Christine merci je vais essayer d'être
concise madame la Présidente donc juste
pour dire au ministre le maire que j'ai
bu ces paroles sur le bonus écologique
et finalement c'est un peu dommage
d'avoir raison trop tôt mais ça fait que
la troisième fois que après m'avoir dit
non vous me dites oui 6 mois plus tard
donc c'est pour faire une technique
peut-être que sur ce texte là j'aurais
aussi raison peut-être après que vous
ayez adopté ou pas refuser ce qu'on ce
qu'on va vous proposer juste pour dire
que sur les articles 17 et 18 on a le
sentiment qu'en fait ce texte de loi est
un peu un bon moyen de légiférer sur des
sujets qui sont parfois un peu ténus
avec le sujet de la transition
écologique notamment parce que dans les
articles 17 et 18 on retrouve des des
dispositions qui ont été adoptées par le
Sénat dans le cas d'une proposition de
loi qui s'appelait protection des
épargnants je ferme cette parenthèse et
pour vous poser deux questions précises
sur le plan épargne climat que vous avez
évoqué la première question sera
pouvez-vous nous indiquer le montant
maximum que pour qui pourra être versé
sur ce plan puisque c'est défini par
avoir réglementaire mais c'est quand
même intéressant de le connaître pour
nous parlementaire et surtout me dire
qu'elle va être la forme de ce véhicule
puisque aujourd'hui le texte est très
elliptique sur ce sujet
j'identifie trois pistes et j'aimerais
savoir laquelle va être retenue soit un
encours qui se régirait par la Caisse
des dépôts et consignations soit un
produit sous enveloppe assurantielle ou
encore une enveloppe de compte titre
vous voyez bien que suivant la forme qui
va être choisie ce n'était pas
exactement le même objet qui sera
proposé aux citoyens et enfin sur
l'article 19 qui prévoit une
législation par ordonnance j'aimerais
que vous nous précisiez un peu plus le
cadre de l'ordonnance j'entends que là
aussi vous voulez utiliser le périmètre
enfin le vecteur législatif pour ne pas
être en retard avec l'entrée en vigueur
de la directive elle TIFF 2.0 en janvier
2024 mais aujourd'hui c'est trop flou
pour savoir ce que vous comptez
exactement faire
très bien et bien sûr ces premières
réactions des rapporteurs je vais vous
laisser monsieur les ministres répondre
merci madame la Présidente je laisserai
pendant lesquieu répondre sur les
questions de procédure de paralysation
question de Didier mon délit et je
répondrai aux trois autres séries de
questions d'abord de combien d'hectares
on parle au total très honnêtement c'est
difficile à évoluer je vais prendre
l'entre-deux je pense que nous parlons
de 15000 hectares nécessaires pour ces
projets industrie vertes certains disent
10000 d'autres 20000 je pense que 20
15000 me paraît raisonnable
s'agissant du nucléaire nous estimons
que le K a été traité dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur le nucléaire avec
toutes les dispositions nécessaires pour
pouvoir mettre sur pied c'est ce nouveau
réacteurs nucléaire obéissant les normes
très spécifiques puisque nous parlons
d'énergie nucléaire
s'agissant du projet d'intérêt
industriel majeur l'objectif est de
concentrer la procédure autour du préfet
pour que les élus étaient intocuteur
unique qui soit un interlocuteur local
et qui permettent de faire valoir ses
droits j'y reviendrai précédemment
le sujet évidemment majeur c'est
le zan bon je salue les travaux qui ont
été menés par le sénateur blanc et par
la présidente l'État sur ce sujet je
pense que on a beaucoup discuté ensemble
ma position est très simple moi je
souhaite que les projets industriels
vertes soit exemptées du zan sans quoi
nous aurons beaucoup de mal et je pense
que les collectivités locales et
départements auront beaucoup de mal
ensuite à faire valoir leurs droits en
matière de foncier de disponibilité de
fonciers il se trouve que
ces décisions seront reprises dans la
proposition de loi qui sera étudiée à
l'Assemblée nationale le 19 juin donc
moi je laisse la sagesse des
parlementaires le choix de savoir si on
exemple du zan uniquement les projets
portant sur l'industrie verte
répondant puisque c'est le critère qu'on
a retenu à la définition comme la
souligner Laurent saumon des actes
européens donc l'éolien les pompes à
chaleur les batteries électriques les
[Musique]
l'hydrogène vert ou et le photovoltaïque
bien entendu ou est-ce que nous
élargissons à d'autres projets
industriels dont nous estimons que il
favorise aussi la transition écologique
moi je ne veux pas appréhenter le débat
il me semble que le minimum c'est de
mettre l'ensemble des projets
industriels répondant à la définition
européenne de l'industrie verte notre
option que je laisse une fois encore à
la sagesse des élus sachant que
la services l'État et le centaure blanc
ont beaucoup travaillé sur le sujet il y
a d'autres options plus larges mais
vraiment moi je laisse ça au débat
parlementaire mais le minimum pour moi
c'est que les projets industriels soient
clairement exclus du calcul du zan faute
de quoi nous aurons beaucoup de mal à
développer cette industrie verte si on
peut insistant sur le sujet mais l'enjeu
est absolument décisif ça ne sert à rien
d'avoir des crédits des projets des
technologies si on n'a pas ce qu'est la
base le foncier et le terrain c'est
vraiment la base de la base et je le dis
de manière très pragmatique en ayant été
obligés parfois de renoncer à des
projets faute de fonciers disponibles
Jean-Yves sur la commande publique moi
je suis tout à fait prêt à demander ce
qui est plus de transparence sur les
nouveaux motifs d'exclusion
c'est nouvelles exclusions pour respect
des obligations environnementales feront
l'objet d'une commission pour inciter
les acheteurs à y avoir recours il y
aura une communication qui sera faite
sur ce sujet là je suis prêt à ce qu'on
fasse toute la transparence sur ce sujet
il faut que l'instrument soit utile et
efficace et vous faites bien nous le
signaler si vous estimez qu'il ne l'est
pas suffisamment pour le moment
Christine Lavarde je rends hommage
effectivement votre position sur le
bonus électrique je vais pas chercher à
me défendre sur le sujet je dis
simplement que dans le fond ici pour se
parler de manière très transparente et
très direct il y a comme toujours deux
visions politiques différentes et je
pense que c'est bien de prendre le temps
de les confronter pour faire des vrais
choix politiques je le redis au sens le
plus noble du terme il y a une vision
sur laquelle la seule chose qui compte
c'est la baisse des émissions de CO2
et la baisse des émissions de CO2 au
niveau national tenir nos objectifs de 0
émissions nettes en 2050 et donc trouver
tous les moyens pour atteindre cet
objectif si le seul objectif c'est de
tenir cette ambition en 2050 quel que
soit les modes de production j'en
connais bien volontiers qui est
peut-être plus rapide d'importer des
véhicules de Chine ou d'ailleurs
simplement le bilan au niveau
international est mauvais le bilan
climatique et le bilan économique au
niveau national alors là il est
catastrophique
parce que vous vous fermez les portes à
la réindustrialisation de la France donc
c'est un vrai choix politique et pour
tout vous dire on en a débattu y compris
au sein du gouvernement
et je vous cache pas que ma vision et
notre vision avec on Lescure n'était pas
forcément majoritaire au départ et puis
finalement dans notre sagesse nous avons
rejoint la vision de Christine Labarde
qui est la deuxième vision qui est de
dire si nous voulons réussir notre
décarbonation tout en renforçant notre
économie il faut que toutes les aides
arrivent à la production
environnementalement la plus vertueuse
c'est-à-dire celle qui est réalisée en
France et en Europe
c'est une autre vision je pense qu'elle
est meilleure pour l'environnement
qu'elle est meilleure pour l'économie et
qu'elle est meilleure pour la société
française on investit sur la
décarbonation notre industrie et sur la
production de véhicules électriques en
France une fois qu'on a fait ce choix
politique on short à des contraintes
techniques parce qu'il y a toujours des
gens pour vous dire il y a qu'à faucon
c'est très simple on réserve le bonus
électrique aux véhicules produit en
France ou en Europe sauf que il y a un
droit européen que vous connaissez
parfaitement et il y a une chose qui
n'est pas possible en Europe je le
regrette parce que très honnêtement ce
serait plus simple c'est de privilégier
le contenu européen c'est ce qui se
pratique en Chine c'est ce qui se
pratique aux États-Unis aux États-Unis
créent d'impôts sont réservés à des
véhicules ou à des productions qui ont
un contenu local suffisamment important
cette voie nous l'avons exploré elle est
sans issue du point de vue du droit
européen je ne désespère pas de changer
le roi européen mais là pour le coup ça
peut prendre un certain temps donc nous
avons choisi une autre voie que la voix
normative c'est-à-dire fixée des
exigences
environnementales suffisamment forte
pour que les aides les bonus électriques
soient effectivement des facto réservés
aux véhicules produits en France ou en
Europe dans des conditions
environnementales plus satisfaisantes
que les véhicules produits en Chine donc
voilà comment est-ce que nous en sommes
arrivés aux conclusions auxquelles
Christine lavande était déjà parvenu
plusieurs années auparavant mais au
ministère de l'Économie des Finances
nous sommes un peu lents et un peu
besogneux
sur le
sur
le produit d'épargne vert
à qui sera-t-il ouvert il est ouvert à
tout enfant de moins de 18 ans il sera
ouvert par les parents il faudra qu'il y
ait une autorisation parentale explicite
un certain nombre de députés m'ont fait
la remarque quand j'ai consulté des
groupes parlementaires nous sommes prêts
évidemment à prendre des amendements sur
ce point tout à fait précis nous
proposons que le montant de ce plan
d'épargne vert soit plafonné à 22
950 euros
nous proposons que ça puisse prendre la
forme soit de fond soit de titre avec
une gestion pilotée pour avoir un
rendement qui soit plus élevé que celui
du livret A tout en ayant une sécurité
je ne dis pas une garantie mais une
sécurité sur le capital versé dans ce
plan de départ
nous proposons en troisième lieu que
cette épargne soit bloquée jusqu'à l'âge
de 18 ans parce que c'est la condition
pour avoir un meilleur rendement et
c'est la condition également pour avoir
une sécurité sur le capital il est
évident que nous prévoyions des clauses
des blocages en cas d'événements
imprévus maladie ou décès par exemple
enfin et c'est évidemment le point
décisif pour ce produit d'épargne vert
je rappelle que nous proposons qui ne
fasse l'objet d'aucun prélèvement fiscal
et d'aucun prélèvement social zéro
charge et 0 impôt je le redis aucun
outil d'épargne dispose davantage
fiscaux aussi important l'exception du
livret A
[Musique]
pour autant le fait qu'aujourd'hui on
parallélise les enquêtes va permettre
des itérations notamment avec
l'allongement de l'enquête publique qui
je pense vont permettre de limiter le
risque que d'éventuelles modifications
du dossier par l'industriel allongent
les délais je pense c'est plutôt un
avantage qu'un inconvénient mais
l'essentiel c'est quand même de
travailler les choses en amont alors
pourquoi ne pas réformer l'enquête
publique oui pourquoi pas je pense qu'on
ouvrira une boîte qui permettrait sans
doute pas d'avoir une audition ce soir
qui se terminerait avant 20h et moi en
20h en 19h45 et surtout une ouverture
des procédures et il faut le reconnaître
des amendements qui sont liés qui
pourraient concerner bien plus que
l'industrie verte l'urbanisme le
logement etc deviendrait l'objet de ce
projet de loi je pense que Bruno Le
Maire quand il a commencé à travailler
ce projet de loi notre première réunion
de travail nous a dit pacte c'était
génial mais il faut reconnaître que
c'était un peu long
et que une fois sorti des procédures
parlementaires c'était même très très
long et qu'on a privilégié un projet de
loi ramassé concentré sur quelques
grands objets et exclusivement destinés
à simplifier accélérer le développement
de l'industrie donc on a préféré et
c'est vrai que ça du coup créer une
procédure nouvelle pour les industries
mais se concentrer sur cette procédure
qui j'espère sera plus efficace avec des
avantages importants je le pense plus
rapide plus efficace et qui permettra y
compris avec l'utilisation des outils
électroniques d'aller plus vite sur
l'impact du projet de loi sur les
dispositions que vous avez adoptées dans
le cadre du projet de loi énergie
renouvelable
j'ai l'impression mais faudra qu'on
précise ça dans les discussions
notamment dans le cadre de l'examen du
projet loi que ce qu'on fait c'est tout
simplement de s'inspirer de ce que vous
avez fait de l'élargir à l'ensemble des
industries et à dans raccourcir les
délais de remplacer le délai maximum de
4 par 3 mois mais il faudra s'en assurer
donc là je suis prêt évidemment nous
sommes prêts à travailler avec vous pour
nous assurer que nous n'avons pas ouvert
une porte dans un coin qui du coup
limiterait les contraintes que vous avez
imposées qui sont essentielles à mon
avis pour les énergies renouvelables
mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
industries vertes donc de notre point de
vue on ne supprime pas une disposition
de la nerf on fait je dirais un article
de coordination qui fait que ce projet
de loi est plus ambitieux trois mois
plutôt 4 et concerne évidemment
notamment les énergies renouvelables
mais pas seulement
j'espère avoir répondu très bien merci
beaucoup alors vous êtes extrêmement
nombreux à poser des questions donc je
vais appliquer la règle de la commission
des affaires économiques un peu
frustrante c'est deux minutes par
personne maximum s'il vous plaît et si
vous pouvez éviter les redondances ça
serait formidable je vais passer la
parole à Olivier Rickman puis à Hervé
gilet
merci madame la Présidente en préambule
monsieur le ministre le maire je vais me
décharger d'une responsabilité
importante c'est que j'ai eu mon
prédécesseur ici au Sénat et à la
commission des affaires économiques tout
à l'heure au téléphone je veux parler de
Michel Raison il m'a chargé de vous
transmettre son bonjour Voilà et la
concote et la cocote ça c'est fait
monsieur le ministre votre projet de loi
entend je cite l'exposé des motifs
accélérer les délais d'implantation des
sites industriels
fort bien mais c'est un peu court depuis
2017 certaines entreprises surtout des
ETI ont eu la chance de bénéficier d'un
accompagnement privilégié des services
de l'État notamment pour l'exportation
avec un succès relatif vu notre déficit
commerciale certains de ces secteurs ont
fait l'objet de mesures ciblées de
simplification des normes et procédures
je pense au numérique les énergies
renouvelables et le nucléaire
et les autres monsieur le ministre je
pense à l'immense majorité des
entreprises dans nos territoires c'est à
dire les PME qui n'ont ni les moyens de
gérer la complexité ni la chance de
bénéficier d'un accompagnement
personnalisé sans une vision systémique
du sujet de la simplification
administrative votre projet de loi
manque à mon sens sa cible il ne faut
pas que simplifier la construction des
usines mais englober toute la chaîne de
valeur toutes les entreprises pas
seulement industrielles dans une
démarche de simplification
je soumettrai avec deux collègues à ce
sujet le 15 juin un rapport à la
Délégation aux entreprises du Sénat j'en
retiens en particulier un chiffre
60 milliards d'euros par an soit 3% du
PIB c'est le coût du fardeau normatif et
réglementaire qui pèse sur les
entreprises alors ma question messieurs
les ministres à défaut de cette démarche
systématique qui manque à votre projet
de loi je pense que vous avez fait une
étude d'impact pouvez-vous nous indiquer
combien d'entreprises vont bénéficier
des articles 2 et 3 de la loi et à
combien l'administration évalue les
économies ainsi réalisées pour ces
entreprises je vous remercie merci
beaucoup notre collègue Hervé gilet
ensuite Franck Montauger
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres
la planification territoriale est
absolument essentielle et donc ce projet
de loi prévoit bien sûr une inscription
dans les sardèdes mais on s'interroge
aujourd'hui de quelle manière les
documents de planification et peut être
particulièrement les scottes vont
prendre en considération ces nouvelles
orientations est-ce que c'est par
obligation préfectorales ou est-ce que
effectivement les scottes seront
véritablement associés l'approche
territorialisée de ce type de projet de
même quand on parle d'estradettes est
interrogée aujourd'hui le rôle et
l'oppositionnement des conseils
régionaux par rapport à l'accompagnement
de la mise en place de ce PGL industrie
verte que recherchez-vous comme objectif
à ce niveau là est-ce que nous sommes
dans un simple exercice de planification
au travers du stradette ou est-ce que
vous recherchez des effets leviers au
travers des conseils régionaux pour
pouvoir accompagner cette politique de
développement et donc dans quel cadre et
dans quel objectif
est-ce que vous souhaitez que cette
stratégie soit clairement inscrite dans
le cadre des CPER ce qui serait quand
même souhaitable pour créer aussi ses
effets leviers avec les politiques
d'État et en fait pour revenir au niveau
des stadettes et notamment à leur
révision si on en croit votre calendrier
cette modification desraded pourrait
donc intervenir courant 2025 ce qui peut
paraître un peu tardif et il y a
peut-être des opportunités de révision
qui seraient plus souhaitable notamment
dans le cadre du calendrier du zinc ce
qui permettrait de gagner un peu du
temps quand on sait aussi la lourdeur de
révision des stradettes ça ne semblerait
effectivement judicieux quel est votre
point de vue sur cette proposition merci
chers collègues ensuite Franck Montauger
puis Jean-Claude Tissot merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur les ministres
pour votre présentation je n'y vois pas
personnellement claire dans le champ non
pas du texte qui est proposé puisque
vous l'avez vous l'avez précisé Monsieur
le Maire
mais je ne vois pas la cohérence par
rapport à la démarche zéro nette
européenne
qui définit huit champs de technologie
stratégiques permettant d'arriver à
l'objectif du 0.net dans le champ que
vous que vous proposez on y trouve pas
par exemple les piles à combustibles les
tout ce qui touche au biogaz au méthane
on y trouve pas du de certaines manières
les électrolyseurs les technologies de
réseau les technologies de réseau
monsieur Lescure monsieur le ministre
Lescure nous avons eu avec vous un débat
il y a quelques semaines ici au Sénat
sur la place de l'hydrogène dans le mix
énergétique français il va falloir
développer sur le territoire national
des des technologies
permettant de fabriquer de mettre du de
l'électricité sur le réseau à partir
d'hydrogène voilà ces technologies sont
fondamentales pour l'avenir pour réussir
les objectifs on ne les voit pas
apparaître dans le dans le dans le champ
de se projeter de loi alors que les
sites ne seront pas utilisés ne seront a
priori pas des sites déjà équipés voilà
il faudra créer des sites à cet effet là
donc moi je trouve que ce périmètre et
bien finalement il a il est un peu
mytheux il y a il y a des trous et il y
a des trous il y a des trous quand même
qui sont importants me semble-t-il pour
pour atteindre les les objectifs que sur
lesquels on est tous d'accord après sur
dernier point la question des
financements je veux bien entendre les 5
milliards d'euros là pour les jeunes ok
je trouve que c'est hors de proportion
avec les besoins de financement
en rapport avec avec le périmètre de la
de la loi quoi voilà
sans compter le fait que ou en redisant
le fait que on est toujours en attente
d'une stratégie énergique climat claire
partagée voilà qui aurait qui aurait dû
être abordé au préalable par don j'étais
trop long merci beaucoup Franck
Jean-Claude Tissot ensuite Bernard but
merci madame la Présidente messieurs et
les ministres j'aurais deux principales
questions sur le projet de loi qui nous
est présenté ce soir la première portera
sur l'article 5 de ce projet de loi qui
propose des mesures facilitant et
accélérant les procédures de
réhabilitation des fiches industrielles
ce ministre Lemaire vous en avez parlé
mais j'ai pas compris exactement on sait
que dans nos territoires et
particulièrement dans les territoires
industriels et miniers comme le mien
département de la Loire la question des
friches est particulièrement complexe
pour les collectivités et peuvent se
retrouver avec des surfaces très
importantes à gérer et des
problématiques bien spécifiques la
salubrité l'aménagement l'accès la
pollution des sols et l'ensemble des
dispositions que vous proposez semble
essentiellement centrer sur des
procédures
je souhaiterais savoir quels sont vos
intentions pour accompagner plus
efficacement les collectivités sur ce
sujet ma deuxième question portera sur
la prise en compte dans ce texte de la
proposition de révision de la directive
sur les émissions industrielles
récemment et examinées au Parlement
européen la portée de la directive a été
élargi lors de ces débats européens avec
notamment la prise en compte des plus
grandes fermes d'élevage les élevages
porcins avicole de plus de 200 UGB oui
c'est ça et les élevages bovins de 300gb
Monsieur le Ministre chargé de
l'Industrie quel a été la position de la
France lors de l'examen de cette
directive notamment sur cette question
de l'élevage et est-ce que ce projet
doit sur l'industrie verte ne pourrait
pas être un premier véhicule intéressant
pour intégrer de nouvelles mesures sur
l'encadrement des émissions
industrielles je vous remercie une 21
madame
merci beaucoup Bernard buis et pour
finir cette première série de questions
Cécile ku Karman merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur les ministres ma
première question pose sur l'intégration
des acteurs territoriaux dans leur
réindustrialisation est-ce que le couple
maire préfet sera l'artisan de la reine
industrialisation dans les territoires
ou bien est-ce que la volonté du
gouvernement repose plutôt sur une
reprise en main via les préfets et donc
la déconcentration plutôt que la
décentralisation dans le cadre de la
sécurisation des approvisionnements en
matière première quelle place le projet
de loi accorde-t-il à l'économie
circulaire en particulier en ce qui
concerne la réutilisation des matériaux
de production au sein d'une même
plateforme industrielle enfin sur les 56
France 2030 la création des 56 France
2030 et la dépollution des friches
industrielles font partie des objectifs
du projet de loi pourriez-vous détailler
les critères de sélection de ces sites
et les actions envisagées pour garantir
leur succès et leur attractivité pour
des investisseurs je vous remercie merci
cher Bernard et Cécile cucarne oui merci
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres vous l'avez rappelé la
gendarle législative à ce site
particulier c'est que la même semaine
nous allons examiner ici votre projet de
loi sur l'industrie verte là où nos
collègues députés examineront le texte
sur le zan et donc finalement nous
allons pouvoir résoudre cette difficulté
qui a irrigué tous les discours des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
quel qu'il soit
l'on veut tous préserver le foncier
agricole on veut tous répondre à la
crise du logement on veut tous
réindustrialiser la France tous
ponctuant les discours par le
qualificatif environnemental à tort ou à
raison chacun bien évidemment déployons
ceci avec ses orientations et ses choix
politiques c'est ainsi en démocratie
chemise dans le projet de loi et vous y
avez fait référence vous parlez de la
requalification des friches c'est
d'abord un défi immense vous l'avez dit
et donc pas du topisme le temps de
requalification des friches n'est pas
celui de la nécessité de l'installation
économique mais si on prend sur une
échelle de 10 à 20 ans et que l'on
qualifie réellement toutes les friches
on les renaturent on libère du foncier
donc du tenement cela permet d'assouplir
considérablement à l'échelle de 10 à 20
ans la pression qui est aujourd'hui
réelle et qui ressenti sur l'ensemble de
nos territoires en matière de zéro
artistication nette des sols ça permet
de redonner envie de faire venir des
industries et cela évite surtout une
fracture qui pourrait se produire qui
est que demain des territoires
accueilleront des nouvelles industries
quand les anciens continueront de garder
leur friche et leur verrerie verrues
pardon en entrée de centre bourg la
question c'est que dans votre texte il
manque un vrai défi qui est celui des
friches anciennes finalement parce que
vous présentez un certain nombre de
mesures pour celles de l'industrie qui
est en train de fermer et de se casser
la figure mais pour toutes les anciennes
riches qui sont très très nombreuses et
qui représentent des milliers des
dizaines de milliers d'hectares rien n'y
est fait et pourtant c'est un vrai défi
première partie de questions ensuite
Henri Cabanel
la présidente sur la première question
d'Olivier Rickman
à mon ami Michel Raison
la démarche sur le parallélisme des
procédures et bien une démarche de
simplification générale on a eu là aussi
un grand débat dans la préparation de ce
projet de loi est-ce qu'il faut faire
une révision des démarches
d'autorisation industrielles uniquement
dans le cadre de l'industrie verte tel
que définie par la loi européenne donc
les cinq projets qu'on a mentionné
précédemment ou est-ce qu'il est
préférable d'avoir une démarche
simplification générale nous avons
retenu une démarche de simplification
générale ça fera probablement débat mais
je pense que c'est la compétitivité du
site France qui est en jeu cela devrait
concerner en tout cas à peu près 1000
entreprises installations ou
agrandissement par an pour répondre plus
précisément à votre demande de chiffrage
sur la question d'Hervé gilet sur les
radettes est-ce que ça peut être un
élément d'accompagnement des plans de
développement moi j'y suis tout à fait
favorable et de manière générale
l'objectif est bien de faire travailler
ensemble j'y reviendrai état et
collectivités territoriale dans le cadre
du radette l'objectif est bien de
participer au développement industriel
en s'appuyant également sur les régions
Franck
montoger je vous rassure l'ensemble du
périmètre du 0 net européen et bien
couvert par le projet de loi simplement
sur l'hydrogène vert nous avons fait le
choix de sortir l'hydrogène vert du
crédit d'impôt pourquoi je suis économie
je suis aussi ministre des Finances donc
je veille à ce que les projets de loi
sont intégralement financés si vous
mettez l'hydrogène vert dans le bénéfice
du crédit d'impôt là vous vous retrouvez
avec des montants qui se chiffre en
plusieurs milliard d'euros il nous
estimons que les 9,2 milliards d'euros
qui ont été mis à titre d'investissement
dans la filière hydrogène vert laquelle
je crois autant que vous vont permettre
le développement d'électrolyseurs de la
recherche sur les valves le soutien aux
start-up elles sont très nombreuses là
il fait d'autres en plus de ce qui est
fait par des grandes entreprises comme
Air Liquide donc nous pensons que
l'argent est suffisant nous pensons que
mettre des crédits d'impôts seraient
excessifs du point de vue budgétaire et
que il vaut mieux s'en tenir à ce qui
est prévu pour le moment soit stratégie
je vous rejoins totalement il est
évident que je le dis très simplement
l'intégralité de l'équilibre de ce
projet loin industrie verte qui comporte
véritables révolutions sur le
financement sur la décision sur les
autorisations qui sont délivrées
ne peut fonctionner que si nous
disposons de l'énergie des carbonées
suffisante pour faire tourner les usines
dont nous parlons qu'est-ce qui fait que
notre véhicule électrique produit en
France avec la chaîne de valeur avec les
batteries électriques avec recyclage des
batteries et même moins de CO2 qu'en
Chine c'est qu'il y a pas d'usine d'un
charbon c'est qu'il y a de l'énergie
nucléaire disponible et de l'énergie
décarbonée disponible encore faut-il que
le marché européen nous permettent d'ici
début 2025 c'est notre objectif d'avoir
comme coût moyen de cette énergie
décarbonée l'équivalence avec le coût
moyen de production c'est le combat que
nous menons avec un espany renaché sur
lequel les lignes bougent
inutile de vous dire que ce n'est pas un
combat facile et je vous rejoins
totalement c'est évidemment le point
absolument clé
je rappelle juste les chiffres on estime
que il faudra disposer à terme de 750
térawh d'énergie pour faire fonctionner
un pays qui se réindustrialise là où
nous en sommes à 450 aujourd'hui
jean-clot Tissot sur les friches
l'objectif est bien d'accompagner plus
efficacement
l'ensemble des collectivités locales en
nous appuyant notamment sur la Caisse
des dépôts et consignations qui
apportera un milliard d'euros à cette
objective j'ai parfaitement conscience
et je réponds aussi à Cécile ku Kerman
dessus nous nous appuierons sur le fond
vert qui est l'ancien fond friche il
faut traiter toutes les actions de
remise en état de ces friches par
ailleurs aussi je reprends ma casquette
d'anciens des locales il faudra c'est
lucide sur le fait que la plupart de ces
friches aujourd'hui ne sont pas
utilisées pour la réindustrialisation la
plupart servent pour des objectifs
tertiaires tout simplement parce que si
elles sont tombées en friche c'est que
très souvent elles étaient en
centre-ville ou à proximité du
centre-ville et que les habitants ne
veulent pas voir ouvrir une usine donc
il faut tenir compte aussi de cette
réalité là dans leur habitation des
friches je ne connais pas la position
française sur qui était pris sur
l'élevage je sais pas si on a une
réponse là-dessus mais je veux pas vous
dire de bêtises
Bernard Bouygues oui objectif est bien
de restaurer le couple mère préfet je
pense qu'il est extrêmement efficace
simplement pour les projets d'intérêt
national
soyons très clair l'interlocuteur c'est
de mise d'économie ou le président de la
République lorsque l'on parle de
l'agrandissement du site de
stmicroelectronique à Grenoble pour des
investissements qui se chiffre en
milliards d'euros le maire le préfet
sont évidemment impliqués mais la
décision relève de discussion directe
entre l'investisseur le ministre de
l'Économie voire le président de la
République il évitant pour prologum
investissement de 6 milliards d'euros il
faut tout le poids du président de la
République pour que nous arrachions cet
investissement
par rapport à d'autres compétiteurs en
Europe ou aux États-Unis je pense que
l'un n'est pas exclusif de l'autre et je
peux vous dire que je m'implique
personnellement sur chaque décision
d'investissement majeur dans notre pays
en obtenant après des résultats qui sont
je pense positifs pour le pays pour les
seules batteries électriques je rappelle
c'est 10000 emplois industriels qui vont
être créés sur quatre gigas Factory 10
000 en points industriels on n'a pas
créé ça depuis quatre décennies notre
pays sur une seule filière enfin Cécile
cuckermann sur les ânes je redis à quel
point
suivant le travail qui a été fait par
notamment Valérie d'État il est à mes
yeux essentiel mais je m'en remets à la
sagesse des députés que soit exclus de
ce calcul des ânes les projets de site
industriel vers ou non mais à minima
vert
nous allons poursuivre
deux mots effectivement sur la directive
la directive iodée j'ai récupéré un peu
d'informations donc c'est vrai que la
Commission voulait élargir de manière
assez large c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire cette directive a des activités
agricoles à ce stade la présidente
suédoise a proposé un compromis qui est
quand même beaucoup plus restreint et
qui viserait à élargir
d'inclure pardon la directive et toutes
les expressions des exploitations pardon
bovine porcine et avicole comptant plus
de 150 unités de gros bétail à ce stade
la France a réservé sa position et
essaie de converger vers une position
évidemment bien moins ambitieuse et du
coup bien moins contraignante pour nos
agriculteurs tout ça devrait être
finaliser d'ici la fin de l'année par la
présidence espagnole très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre Henri
Cabanel l'impuis Amel gacquère merci
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres ma question portée sur sur le
la loizanne et l'exemple donc une
entreprise biterroise dans l'Hérault que
le Président de la République était venu
visiter l'entreprise genvia donc faire
de l'anse de la filière hydrogène vert
mais vous avez répondu à la question
puisque vous avez dit que ces
entreprises seraient exemptées de la
loizan donc ce qui permettra donc
d'éviter le casse-tête donc des élus
locaux pour à la fois installer donc ces
gigafactory donc très consommatrice de
fonciers et en même temps donc installé
les PME donc voilà je ne serai pas plus
long et je merci d'avoir répondu en
espérant d'ailleurs que votre collègue
donc Christoph e Béchu et bien sûr sur
la même ligne que vous
Henri pour la concision Amel gaker puis
Serge babary madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
élus dans le Pas-de-Calais je ne peux
pas ne pas à mon tour évoquer saluer
l'implantation d'acc inaugurée hier donc
la première gigafactory de batterie
électrique dans un territoire
historiquement industriel territoire qui
grâce aux trois autres projets de
gigafactory est en train de connaître un
véritable tournant vers l'automobile de
demain et ce et je pense que c'est
important de le soutenir souligner grâce
à la mobilisation de tous et le locaux
collectivités territoriales états et
entreprise cette usine c'est 2000
emplois et 500 000 voitures équipées de
batterie électrique d'ici 2030 plus
globalement pardon les objectifs de
cette gigafactory rejoignent les axes
retenus dans ce projet de loi la
création d'emploi la décarbonation
pardon de notre industrie à la fin la
défense de notre souveraineté
industrielle dans un secteur stratégique
celui de la batterie électrique
l'ambition du gouvernement est donc à
saluer cependant subsiste quelques
interrogations sur l'écosystème
industriel et sur la chaîne de valeur je
souhaite aborder un point qui n'a pas
été évoqué alors qu'il demeure pour ma
part déterminant dans votre volonté
commune de verdir notre industrie la
décarbonation de notre industrie sera
fortement consommatrice de métaux
critiques or les dépendances
stratégiques de notre économie notamment
à la matière pourrait compromettre
l'objectif d'un d'une véritable
réindustrialisation verte pour exemple
chaque voiture électrique va nécessiter
10 kg de lithium en moyenne
mais question sont les suivantes le
gouvernement a-t-il pris la mesure des
besoins de notre industrie en matière
d'approvisionnement matériaux en métaux
pardon critique et quelle est sa
position sur l'extra du lithium métal
stratégique pour la décarbonation de
notre industrie pour rappel la France
compte une quarantaine de sources selon
le bureau de recherche géologique et
minières je vous remercie merci beaucoup
Amel Serge babary ensuite Sylviane Noël
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres je voudrais évoquer deux
thèmes le premier celui de la logistique
logistique à la campagne automatiquement
le développement industriel et quand on
parle de de giga Factory il faut
imaginer immédiatement à proximité
des installations importantes en
logistique pour éviter justement des
transports à longue distance pour à la
fois approvisionner les industries mais
aussi stocker sans doute les produits
finis
j'ai bien entendu que vous indiquiez que
les éléments de d'accélération des
procédures
euh
il y aura une simplification générale
donc j'imagine que ça touchera
l'installation des bâtiments de
logistique dont je viens de parler mais
à côté de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
simplification en amont c'est-à-dire
jusqu'au jusqu'au dépôt du dossier il y
a aussi les problèmes en aval qui sont
parfois longs il s'agit des recours et
je voudrais attirer votre attention en
particulier pour la logistique les
ressources sont nombreux et il faudrait
imaginer de pouvoir agir contre les
recours abusifs parfois de la part
d'associations qui n'ont aucun lien avec
le territoire et qui permettent qu'il
faudrait pouvoir permettre une réduction
de l'intérêt agir pour éviter de bloquer
un des éléments clés du développement
industriel parce que c'est un
accompagnement essentiel je parle donc
de la logistique le deuxième sujet je
voulais évoquer c'est le financement
vous l'avez indiqué moi je m'intéresse
particulièrement au financement des PME
et ti dans les territoires
il s'agit
d'entreprises qui peuvent concourir
à l'industrie verte et qui recherche des
financements je reviens sur une idée que
j'ai développé à plusieurs reprises ici
ce défaut régionaux parce que pour le
financement l'article 18 indique bien
soutien développement des fonds
européens d'investissement pour les ETI
et PME mais dans les territoires on peut
mobiliser je pense des fonds lever des
fonds régionaux ça se passe dans
certaines régions et ça devrait
développer justement à l'occasion de
l'industrie verte pour le PME local
merci beaucoup Serge Silvia Noël ensuite
Valérie Létard merci madame la
Présidente messieurs les ministres ma
question porte sur deux points le
premier point est relatif à la
diminution de l'empreinte carbone et
plus particulièrement au triple
afférents pouvez-vous nous confirmer que
le un nouveau standard sera basé sur les
caractéristiques des standards et labels
existants et que ce standard ne sera pas
uniquement français mais qu'il
s'inscrira bien dans les standards
européens pour faciliter la capacité des
entreprises à intégrer ces nouveaux
standards il ne semble en effet pas
nécessaire de réinventer quelque chose
il existe déjà suffisamment de labels et
d'autres parts je souhaite vous alerter
sur les inquiétudes qui portent sur les
le crédit un peu recherche car le
gouvernement a déjà prévenu que les
dépenses devront être financées par des
économies équivalentes la perspective
d'un coup de rabot du Crédit Impôt
Recherche et notamment sur celui qui
porte sur les dépenses de veille
technologiques ou de bonification de
crédits pour recherche pour l'embauche
de jeunes docteurs alors même que c'est
un dispositif
efficace sur la dynamique de
l'innovation serait contre-productif car
il n'y aura pas de rien
industrialisation sans capacité à
innover et à transformer nos innovations
en produits pouvez-vous nous rassurer
sur ce point je vous remercie merci
beaucoup Sylviane Valérie Létard ensuite
Anne-Catherine Loisier j'annonce que je
ne prends plus d'inscription parce que
sinon ça va aller trop loin merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues
merci d'abord à monsieur le ministre
Bruno Le Maire d'avoir pris attention à
la question
corollaire et en tout cas indissociable
qui existe entre la maîtrise du foncier
le zéro artificialisation nette et
l'industrie verte et la nécessité
effectivement rappelée monsieur le
ministre de s'inquiéter de la façon dont
serait décompté ou non le foncier
mobilisé pour l'industrie dans le cadre
des enveloppes des scottes et des
régions à une petite subtilité Prémo
semi sur lequel j'aimerais vous
interroger parce que ça nous taraude
beaucoup et c'est vraiment au cœur de la
réflexion c'est que il y a plusieurs
façons de le dire on peut dire présenter
exclu comptait à part il y a une
question qui reste entière et qui n'est
pas tranchée je pense entre les uns et
les autres c'est celle de la
mutualisation qui nous est dite lorsque
nous auditionnons par exemple notre
ministre de l'écologie monsieur Béchu
qui nous dit oui on compte à part mais
nous souhaitons mutualiser c'est-à-dire
répartir entre les régions mais ce qui
veut dire monsieur le ministre en clair
que on va partager l'effort entre les 13
régions et que ça veut dire qu'en plus
des 50% qui seront comptés de
l'enveloppe des scottes on additionnera
les projets d'intérêt nationaux donc
monsieur le ministre là-dessus c'est
vrai que nous aimerions connaître votre
position c'est-à-dire est-ce que c'est
une exemption totale et sans redescente
au niveau régional c'est important vous
avez parlé beaucoup Monsieur Mitz de
quelque chose qui nous tient à coeur
c'est la la coopération le partage qu'il
nous semble essentiel d'avoir avec des
régions et des intercommunalités
compétentes en la matière de stratégie
de développement industriel et la façon
dont vous allez construire choisir
identifier procéder à l'élaboration et
au choix avant de remonter ces projets
au niveau d'un décret en Conseil d'État
et là-dessus avec la PP alzane nous
avons aujourd'hui au cœur de nos
préoccupations la nécessité de rédiger
quelque chose qui fasse écho à votre
texte mais qui puisse globalement être
atterrir dans les régions asradettes on
peut pas l'écrire en trois fois on doit
l'écrire en une fois et l'organiser et
trouver quelque chose qui permette en
même temps la souplesse donc monsieur le
ministre c'est très important de
continuer à travailler ensemble sur ce
sujet puis un dernier point une seconde
ministre quand on fait de l'industrie on
a besoin de salariés et quand on a des
salariés il faut les loger il y a
quelque chose qui relève de votre
périmètre de responsabilité qui est le
devenir d'Action Logement et là-dessus
monsieur le ministre nous aimerions
connaître votre sentiment votre avis sur
le classement on a pu par l'INSEE sur
souvenirs de la convention qui lit
Action Logement
c'est important monsieur le ministre
parce que ce qu'on sera capable de
mobiliser comme moyen pour financer le
logement des salariés et déterminant si
beaucoup Valérie Anne-Catherine Loisier
ensuite Vanina paoliga merci Madame à
présent de messieurs les ministres juste
deux points complémentaires j'espère en
tout cas
tout ne sera pas décarboné donc il y
aura aussi de la compensation
et je voudrais savoir ce que vous
envisagez pour notamment fléché la
compensation on valorisant
prioritairement les puits de carbone de
nos métropoles ou de nos outre-mer donc
les puits de carbone essentiellement
agricoles et forestiers afin de
favoriser aussi quelque part la
transition écologique et l'adaptation de
ces espaces et puis deuxième question
qui qui est peut-être un peu anticipée
je sais pas si vous l'avez évoqué mais
je voudrais savoir ce qu'il en serait
exactement des crédits d'impôts de la
question des crédits d'impôt sur les
investissements étrangers qui a pu être
évoqué et qui serait finalisé dans un
deuxième temps en PLF est-ce que c'est
une idée qui a été mise de côté en tout
cas voilà nous expliquer pourquoi il
faudrait des crédits d'impôts sur les
investissements étrangers et pas
forcément dans sur d'autres secteurs
merci beaucoup Anne Catherine Vanina
paoligajin puis pour finir Michel
Calmette merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour cette
présentation je j'ajouterai monsieur le
ministre Lemaire juste au sinistre que
vous avez égrainé un que vous avez je
pense
omi qui est que notre
désindustrialisation a beaucoup pesé
aussi sur notre capacité à atteindre
notre objectif de Lisbonne puisqu'en
fait deux tiers de la R&D provient de
l'industrie donc remettre en route notre
industrie c'est aussi reprendre place
par rapport à l'objectif qu'on sait
nous-mêmes fixé deux petites questions
qui concernent essentiellement le
financement et qui vous intéresse en
fait tous les deux amont et aval
effectivement nous saluons le drainage
de l'épargne public enfin de financer
cette industrie je m'interroge sur le
dispositif par exemple du PER sur les
allocations d'actifs en fait
sous-jacents je vois que c'est du côté
et donc là je rejoins un peu
ce qui est dit mon collègue gabarit je
voudrais quand même qu'on s'assure qui
est aussi des quotas de non côté qui
puissent bénéficier de ces dispositifs
d'épargne qu'on va drainer auprès des
français et deuxième point je voulais
savoir si vous pensez qu'il faudrait
aussi qu'on ait des poches
d'investissement ou des véhicules dédiés
à la consolidation stratégique d'acteurs
plus petit des PME PMI ETI pour créer de
nouveaux champions industriels français
beaucoup et Michel canevett merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur les ministres
collègues je veux saluer l'engagement du
département du gouvernement pour la
réindustrialisation de la France
cela se passe d'ailleurs le jour où la
presse régionale de Bretagne
annonce labandon du projet
d'installation près de Rennes de l'usine
Bridor et de ses 500 emplois un an et
demi après que les premiers recours au
tribunal administratif étaient engagés
et je voudrais à cet égard demander si
dans le fléchage des investissements
est-ce qu'il est prévu une répartition
sur l'ensemble du territoire national où
va-t-on uniquement privilégier les
territoires peut-être au loto de chômage
est le plus élevé je parlais notamment
des Hauts de France puisque c'est là que
sont localisés et une partie des
investissements et puis comme Amel gaker
je suis aussi préoccupé par le recours
aux matières premières est-il envisagé
des dispositions pour permettre ce
recours aux matières premières en dehors
du recyclage des métaux précieux bien
entendu
merci beaucoup Michel vous me
permettrait quelques petites questions
rapides à la fin à mon tour j'aurais
voulu savoir si sur les crédits d'impôts
et sur les bénéfices fiscaux qui va qui
vont sous tendre le soutien à cette
industrie
vertes ou il y aura des conditionnalités
des aides sur la durée pour rester dans
le pays ou sur un certain nombre
d'autres
éléments j'aurais également voulu
rappeler sur le fond friche puisqu'il a
été évoqué plusieurs fois que ce font
friche enfin le fond vert devenu vert de
2 milliards sans être taquine et pour
moitié
destiné à compenser la CVAE pour les
départements donc est-ce que le milliard
restant va suffire compte tenu du fait
que il y a aussi le fond Barnier qui est
dedans et un certain nombre d'autres
font et je voudrais aussi me
capacité sur que vous parliez monsieur
le ministre Bruno Le Maire du bilan
carbone parce que il a été introduit
avec beaucoup de difficultés au Sénat
par notre collègue Daniel Gremillet qui
est là et nous pensons en effet que
c'est le bon outil pour mesurer ce que
nous devons faire en matière écologique
voilà je vais vous laisser peut-être
répondre à l'ensemble de ces questions
et on sera à peu près dans les temps je
pense connaissant votre concision merci
madame la Présidente et merci de votre
efficacité reconnue
Henri Cabanel je pense que j'ai répondu
sur les ânes j'y reviendrai plus tard
mais sur hydrogène vert je vous redis
que nous voulons soutenir les projets
des start-ups comme des PME
sur la question des
matériaux critiques vous transmettrez ma
réponse qui s'adresse également à
Michel Calvet c'est évidemment un point
tout à fait essentiel notre stratégie
repose sur trois piliers avec un
objectif stratégique qui est de
maîtriser l'intégralité de la filière il
s'agit pas uniquement de produire les
batteries électriques il faut maîtriser
l'intégralité de la filière je
recommande une nouvelle fois d'aller
visiter l'usine à CC vous verrez que
c'est impressionnant c'est des outils
industriels comme il en existe peu en
Europe de complexité de technologie de
taille donc à partir du moment où on
fait les investissements pareil il est
bon d'avoir aussi l'amont et Laval c'est
à dire le recyclage en amont le plus
important c'est d'avoir un accès
sécurisé au matériau critique en
particulier le lithium donc nous avons
pour ça demander un délégué un
tamistériel travailler sur le sujet
confié de mission à Philippe Varin qui
nous a remis des propositions sur le
sujet nous travaillons également une
stratégie européenne de diversification
des sources qui peut être orientée vers
le Canada vers l'Amérique du Sud ou vers
l'Indonésie et nous voulons évidemment
travailler sur l'ouverture de mines je
rappelle qu'il y a une mine qui se
trouve dans l'Allier de la mine d'iméris
qui est remise en état de fonctionnement
qu'il y a d'autres projets qui sont à
l'étude en Alsace donc nous avons des
possibilités d'ouvrir des mines de
lithium dans des conditions
environnementales satisfaisantes vous
avez vu qu'au Portugal ou le sujet avait
soulevé énormément de controverse
finalement un accord appelé de trouver
qui préserve à la fois les intérêts
environnementaux et les intérêts de
sécurité d'approvisionnement donc je
pense que ça c'est la première source
possible sécuriser notre
approvisionnement en utilisant les
ressources nationales
les ressources européennes j'ai cité le
Portugal je pourrais citer aussi la
Suède j'ai rencontré un des grands
producteurs de météo critiques en Suède
lorsque j'ai mis sur rendu il y a
quelques jours l'Amérique du Sud et le
Canada et l'Indonésie pour des
territoires plus lointains premier
pilier la sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement deuxième pilier
c'est la stratégie circulaire de
recyclage et de réutilisation des
matériaux le projet qui était ouvert
notamment avec Orano et un acteur
chinois doit nous permettre de récupérer
les matériaux critiques qui sont sur les
batteries
usagées sont les technologies là aussi
qui sont des technologies
extraordinairement pointues que de
maîtrise que quelques pays à travers le
monde pas plus de trois ou quatre la
France fera partie des pays qui
maîtriseront ces technologies et qui
pourront par conséquent récupérer par
recyclage les matériaux critiques dans
les batteries enfin troisième
orientation c'est d'être déjà dans
l'innovation vers d'autres batteries
plus performantes et moins consommatrice
de métaux critiques je pense au ion
lithium solide aujourd'hui SSC c'est du
lion lithium liquide c'est la
technologie qui va être utilisée par
prologum qui permettra d'utiliser moins
de matériaux critiques que ceux qui sont
utilisés actuellement
Serge babary genou oui bien sûr je pense
que ça peut être tout à fait utile de
les mobiliser et de les utiliser
Sylvain Noël sur le triple e il s'agit
bien Sylviane pardon d'utiliser les
caractéristiques des labels existants
dans le cadre européen
il s'agissant du cire je veux être très
clair nous avons écarté toute
modification du cygne parce que nous
estimons que le bilan coût avantage est
négatif l'avantage qu'on pouvait
récupérer quelques dizaines de millions
d'euros voire davantage pour financer le
projet de loi le défaut c'est que cela
crée de l'instabilité pour les
investisseurs avec le risque de nous
faire perdre un de nos grands avantages
comparatifs par rapport aux autres
nations européennes en matière
d'attractivité donc il n'a pas été
retenu de modification du cire dans le
cadre de ce projet de loi je vais être
très clair sur le sujet
Valérie Létard aussi je vais être très
clair et transparent je suis favorable à
ce que les projets d'industrie vertes
que ce soit les projets d'intérêt
national où les autres projets de PME et
de TI soit exclus du calcul du zan je
sais que d'autres plaident pour que il y
ait un compte à part je pense que à
force de compter à part beaucoup de
projets on va se retrouver avec
l'intégralité du pays qui va se trouver
mis en stock et difficile ensuite à
répartir donc c'est ma position je le
dis très simplement sa position de mise
de l'économie et des finances elle n'est
pas encore définitivement AR mais je
pense qu'il faut que chacun réalise que
la course que nous sommes engagés est
difficile elle fera quelques gagnants
très peu et beaucoup de perdants et que
je préfère que la France compte parmi
les gagnants et croyez moi pour me
battre avec mes équipes depuis plusieurs
années sur chaque investissement chaque
investissement demande des milliers
d'heures de travail et d'engagement des
équipes techniques et des responsables
politiques donc je vais mettre tous les
atouts de mon côté et si nous commençons
à expliquer que on va stocker en réserve
des projets industriels stratégiques il
y a fort à parier qui iront ailleurs
qu'en France donc on aura plus rien à
stocker du tout donc je préfère qu'il
soit exclu
sur les puits carbones ça tout à fait
prêt à regarder ce qui peut être fait le
crédit d'impôt je rappelle qu'il est
pour les investissements fait en France
mais ça peut des investissements
français vous investissements étrangers
peu importe
s'agissant vanilla polygagen du PER les
actifs sont les actifs non cotés donc je
pense que ça répond à votre question des
allocations sans obligation en tout cas
[Musique]
pour faire des amandes je suis un peu
voilà tout cela mérite d'être approfondi
et je pense que le débat nous permettra
de préciser les choses
Michel Canevet sur la répartition par
territoire des investissements très
franchement c'est la disponibilité du
foncier qui en général décide de
l'investissement il se trouve si on est
tout à fait honnête que aujourd'hui le
premier bénéficiaire de ces
investissements industriels ce sont les
hauts de France pour des raisons qui
sont assez intéressantes et du foncier
disponible puisque évidemment il y a des
friches il y a la disponibilité d'un
port de premier plan Dunkerque et vous
avez élément de son décisifs en tout cas
pour prologum une centrale nucléaire qui
la centrale de Gravelines qui permet
d'approvisionner en électricité
décarbonée un coût compétitif il me
semble que dans un territoire qui était
tellement marqué par la
désindustrialisation ça n'est que
justice voir revenir des investissements
industriels mais il faut évidemment que
toute la nation puisse en bénéficiant
enfin pour répondre à la présidente oui
il y aura une conditionnalité au crédit
d'impôt puisque ne seront éligibles au
cahiers d'impôts que un certain nombre
de secteurs clairement définis et que
l'ensemble des entreprises devront avoir
rempli leur obligations
environnementales notamment de bilan des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
rappelle que c'est une obligation légale
de
produire son bilan des élections de gaz
à effet de serre et que aujourd'hui seul
53% des entreprises ont rempli cette
obligation
pour compléter un arme la présidente
donc sur les matériaux de base on va
même au-delà puisqu'on a sélectionné le
fond qui va nous permettre de gérer des
encours de manière à financer des
projets d'extraction de matériaux rares
ou de matériaux miniers en France ou à
l'extérieur on a sélectionné le front
infravia l'état mettra 500 millions et
l'objectif c'est que le fond infrabra
lève jusqu'à 2 milliards d'euros un
milliard de cette année de milliards à
terme y compris auprès de clients
potentiels donc de constructeurs de
batterie et autres le ministre l'a dit
le recyclage est important parce qu'à
terme ça permettra évidemment
d'accroître la compétitivité du site
français Europe vis-à-vis des batteries
mais aussi de limiter les extractions et
puis la notre capacité collective à
faire de ce qu'on appelle du de
l'extraction responsable et donc comme
vous l'avez dit au niveau du Portugal il
faut qu'on fasse dans le monde entier
qu'on impose des critères qui font que
le notre capacité à miner soit soit
responsable et reconnu comme tel que ce
soit une contrainte pour les matériaux
de base en Europe il y avait une
question sur les recours abusifs du
sénateur barbarie bon c'est un sujet
délicat parce que le droit au recours
vous savez constitutionnel mais nous
sommes ouverts à des propositions
parlementaires sur les recours abusifs à
ce stade qu'on a prévu de faire mais
c'est le niveau réglementaire c'est dans
le cadre des projets d'intérêt national
majeurs qu'on puisse envisager des
dispositions particulières pour le
contentieux con supprime un degré de
juridiction d'immat on démarre
directement qu'on appelle comme ça a été
fait pour le projet de loi honneur avec
un délai de jugement limité à 10 mois
nous sommes évidemment prêts à examiner
d'autres dispositions si vous avez des
idées si la présente clotorise il y a
deux derniers points que j'ai oublié de
mentionner d'avoir la réponse sur le
classement en appuie de la dette
d'Action Logement j'ai vu à deux
reprises le président d'Action Logement
je pense que nous trouverons un accord
ensemble pour tenir compte des réserves
d'Action Logement sur ce sujet il y a un
recours je pense qu'il faut respecter
les délais de justice il y a un deuxième
point que je voulais absolument
mentionné c'est sur les outre-mer je
rentre d'un déplacement de deux jours en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe je pense
qu'il est très important ce n'est pas le
cas pour le moment dans le projet de loi
qui est des dispositions spécifiques
pour outre-mer qui regorge de projets
industrie verte très intéressant qui
fait face à des contraintes spécifiques
que vous connaissez parfaitement
auxquelles il me semble important que
nous répondions dans ce projet de loi
j'avais une question ce sens et
notamment les équivalences normatives
l'empreinte elles ont un impact
considérable sur l'empreinte carbone
puisque pour bénéficier de bois de
Guyane de bois du Brésil il doit
traverser l'Atlantique pour avoir un
tampon leur européenne et revenir et
j'en passe c'est parfois aussi tout ce
que nous voulons arriver à régler qui
m'a été souligné de manière très claire
lors de mon déplacement je vous remercie
très bien merci beaucoup il me reste à
vous remercier tous les deux ainsi que
l'ensemble de votre équipe pour cette
première audition mais qui sera suivie
probablement de rencontres de
questionnements et d'échanges merci aux
rapporteur d'avoir été là et merci aux
membres de la commission